On Twitter.
You know,
Milo wants say mean things block mute.
You know what I'd do?
I press yes.
Yeah,
the block people.
I blocked some people.
Yeah,
the Milo one was very,
very weird.
They were looking for a re and here's the other part of it.
You know what he ultimately got in trouble air quotes for was him talking about
the positive experiences that he had as a young man being molested.
I think that was after he was already band though.
I don't think so.
Well,
he might've been banned from Twitter already,
but then he got kicked off of Youtube and he left,
I don't think,
say it off youtube.
He's,
I think he's still on youtube was it was at Breitbart that he left fired.
He quit Breitbart,
Breitbart.
It's another thing too though,
you know,
I see all these journalists writing all these articles saying like Milo has
gone,
Milo is whining and he's no more.
I'm like,
dude,
it's got like 6 million followers across his Instagram is youtube and his
Facebook.
He posts all the time.
Yeah,
the journey.
He's not in the public conversation as much as he was before because Dave
censored them when you're not on Twitter.
Right.
The journalists who make up the huge core of their verified users who apparently
according to seen on a car like the lifeline,
their platform,
I'm talking,
I'm talking about you,
but here's my point.
He's not saying that men should go have sex with younger boys.
He was basically saying that it could be a positive experience because it was
for him.
Why don't I don't know anything about what happened in that capacity in my,
my point was if I said when I was 13 a 21 year old girl fondled me,
do you think I'd get in trouble if I said it was awesome?
No,
I better wouldn't.
You wouldn't.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
My brother was pointing out because a law and order Svu is basically on 24 seven
it's like 98% of the episodes are only ever about women,
never about men being victims.
Sometimes they are,
but he was like,
oh,
I just realized that and I was like,
let's decide here.
Well,
that's special victims unit.
That's the show.
I mean the,
the,
they have so many versions of law and order,
but that one in particular where I don't know,
but I mean it deals with sex crimes.
Yes.
And almost every episode,
it rarely ever talks about male victims.
Right.
Which exists,
you know what I mean?
And so I don't want to get like into a men's rights thing,
but no,
I think it's fairly obvious to a lot of people,
like you mentioned.
Yeah.
If you said it,
nobody would care it but Milo's gay.
Right.
And so that becomes,
you know,
becomes a thing for him.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
um,
there's,
we need some kind of clear guidelines,
right.
Where you can operate inside these guidelines and all's fair.
It's just,
I mean,
to an extent,
it is tough shit.
Comedians will be allowed to operate dancing on the line.
You know what I mean?
Like obviously I think so.
Right,
right.
I'll tell you,
I can't tell you this shit.
I'll tell you something after this is over.
That's going to,
you're going to think it's hilarious and we'll find out about it in the future.
Oh,
and everyone's going to be eating secret.
No,
no,
no.
It's not a secret.
It's a comedy secret.
It's about something.
But you know what she said,
but I'll take this out to you to remind me,
but I'll take this opportunity to segue into another point when it comes to the
bias,
right?
How is it that you can have Jimmy Kimmel,
Jimmy Fallon dress in black face on there?
Uh,
CNN made a big list.
I don't know exactly when it happened.
I think,
uh,
Kimball was on the man show.
He dressed like a basketball player.
Oh Geez.
And Jimmy Fallon.
Just like Chris Rock.
Oh,
Jesus.
Sarah Silverman did it.
She,
I think she addressed it though.
Yes.
Everybody,
nobody loses their minds.
Nobody loses their minds over that because they're on the left.
You think?
I Dunno.
It's,
it's,
I,
I honestly,
I would say to an extent,
there's probably some kind of tribal bias.
Well,
I think when you're going back to high school yearbooks,
looking for outrage from 55 year old people,
if you've lost the plot,
isn't that?
Isn't that crazy?